I'm eating all this food out of a fart
bag and then I'm taking all these pills
to see if it's gonna make my fart smell
good so my question to you is will you
smell my farts later here goes nothing
it's like the matrix for my butthole my
magic little fart pills are flowers that
we're gonna go home and like fire our
brains out No fun's just getting started
it's about to be an atomic adventure of
[ __ ] that was allowed so far
etiquette like I hold it in at my
workplace and like on the subway cuz I'm
not a monster I think the proper for
netiquette is farting and getting away
with it
fart in peace FIP men FIP not that you
should suppress your real self but I
would say just go to the bathroom to
fart because ain't nobody want to smell
your farts a fart either it's coming out
or it's not like if I go all the way to
the bathroom
it's got farting especially for women is
like so taboo like women no women don't
poop but that just makes me want to fart
more I farted so many times in the
bedroom over the weekend I started
yelling at her oh my gosh I stink so bad
and then she's like Jayde I didn't fart
this from you two hours ago I was like
damn girl you love me I had dreamed of
creating a pill that would make your
farts smell like Cinnabons can't really
take a pill that makes your farts less
stinky so what if I told you that
absolutely a hundred percent I'd be
interested then I could eat dairy as
much as I wanted this is what my dreams
look like it's not even in English guys
it's French so you know it's fancy see
you in French people fart did you tell
my mom period a big faux pas to me roof
it and have unit a fart sing pill to
perfume your fart with a violent flavor
and it's made mostly of a cold activated
charcoal yeah gelatin and blueberry I
don't think anything is gonna make my
farts smell any better but I'm willing
to give it a try I'm optimistic all the
way this honestly could change my life
what if one of us thinks that they're
safe because of this and farts at work
and like stinks up the whole place
welcome to Anita's fart cam the farts
are real raw and smelly I'm gonna check
this milk you see if this pill okay I'm
good you really need to test out my
farts on people dee I have a part of the
first time I ever farted in any
significant other try and kick things up
a notch with cheese just in time for
this experiment
Bart town I'm a little gassy if I do
fart it'll it'll probably smell like
roses yeah I can't see why I wouldn't be
okay with that
what do y'all think about farting in the
office
let it do it so maybe I can you need to
part time from my fart bag I am feeling
a rumble in my tummy so I did some
research online to see what foods baby
Clark supposedly fruit is good she's
gonna have a little bit more fruit to my
fart box Wheat Thins have three grams of
fiber I haven't had any gas yet I'm
gonna beef it up a little bit get some
beans maybe get some broccoli and cheese
I just let out a little toot it was
quiet
it was simplest I think I'm really
building up to something good almost
done hot chocolate hopefully when I'm
done I'll be some flowers and gasses and
lavender huge protruding from my booty
halfway through the day I'm at farts
haven't smelled any better take myself
another fart pill tooth my suits can
smell sweeter I was trying to prevent
down in the same facility in which I
farted and I cannot smell it and that
can be worse or anything
will you smell my I've gotten them all
today
[Music]
I did I'd find a few minutes ago and
that's the Chelsea and she didn't
realize it and I was trying to with it I
didn't get in I got a neutral smell
I feel like he's trying to create a
filter for my farts for my far too light
just let me yeah be free and stinky I'm
gonna kick it up another notch question
is will it make my first smell like a
lavender nope I just burped and it
smelled like chili thanks to the mass of
that [ __ ] they didn't smell like
lavender thought I had to fart but I
actually had to take a [ __ ] so I'm glad
I went to the bathroom that's the
problem I keep wanting to and then I
lose it so put these those make me stop
burning that's what I'm yeah constipated
so sadly it was a pretty fart free work
day today just to really take things to
the extreme I'm gonna heat up some hot
dogs that I've left over from Labor Day
toss them in there I'm about to bust
into this chili with bean
Roadhouse if this can't make me party
nothing can no definitely not laughing
OH
I'll fill the room up with farts and
then learn people into this room
no it smells like people is it possible
that this is a success because I did
part we acknowledged it Erik heard the
fart no one smells anything
Sarah fart when Tunisia Bell hell yeah
they smell been a little bit frustrating
my stomach is full and I haven't really
found the full effects of it I went to a
workout class I farted outside on the
street I didn't smell anything but you
know the best thing about farting while
you're walking is a good old crop dust
so it's been about 30 minutes since the
punishment Shelly and oh we had one part
as potent and did not smell like
lavender I still have a shirt
it just happened do you smell anything
correct that's good should I be smelling
flowers anything
maybe it's neutralized cuz I don't smell
like a field of lavender but I also
don't smell a part my fiance's refusing
to spoil my farts pardon he's not but I
just did one and it does it's more good
I mean my main problem with this is like
it says it's like French I feel like a
true French attitude is I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm about to go ask my girlfriend
if she can smell my fart hope it's a
silent way there's no way that you just
started
I don't smell anything there's something
that doesn't sit right with me about the
fart uncertainty that happens when you
fart and you can't smell him whoo-hoo
that was loud and that was proud yep I'm
calling it these pills do not work farts
are gonna smell like farts I've never
seen in my pants but this morning when I
farted like my fart smell it's so
intense and I was like damn like was
that all the smell backed up from
yesterday that's what I was the smell
was so incredibly bad this morning like
it was making me sick
because I was just farting left and
right mitt did not nothing could
neutralize the smell so I kind of see
like that prolonged party this perhaps
this pill delayed the farts or the
intensity of the smells for like a
situation that I don't want to fart I'll
just like rely on B you know or like
anti gas pills I do not trust these
pills enough to neutralize the smell of
the fart whatever like I don't want to
stink I would definitely like keep it
like we're just in case break in case of
emergency situations the amount of [ __ ]
that are shoving in my stomach like I
should have gotten the tummy grumbles I
got tummy grumbles that's not what's
talking all evening after I took three
of those pills like